in the course of living crisis there's
one number that matters above them all
it is inflation the rate at which prices
of services and goods are rising each
year and they certainly are rising the
high this line is the higher that
inflation rate is you can see it's gone
up up up up up in the last few years and
now it's at 10.1 percent that's the
joint highest it's been since 1982 but
what's interesting here is if you break
that down into the kind of basket of
goods and services that comprise
inflation you get a sense of what's
going on beneath the surface so for
instance you can see all sorts of things
here clothing and Footwear pushing it up
transport costs as well obviously petrol
prices there but look at the red segment
that red segment is food food and
non-alcoholic drinks that is rising
really fast about 14 15 at the last gasp
and that is contributing to inflation
why because actually food prices are in
part a consequence of higher fertilizer
prices which is in part a consequence of
you've guessed it Energy prices it's
really an energy story and actually
there is a little bit of good news here
I want to share with you when we look at
Energy prices it's rare that we get good
news recently at the moment isn't it
this is gas prices wholesale gas prices
and you can probably see look this is
the prices that are paid on the market
but it's quite a similar shape isn't it
to the last chart we showed you look
they were really high in September but
see what's happened since then they've
come down actually down let me highlight
that down to round about the lowest
they've been uh 45 peer therm since
getting towards kind of late 2020 so
that's pretty encouraging who knows
where it's going to go next because you
know we found some four Stones before
but if that stays where it is then that
could be good news for inflation but
here's the thing that the government is
focused on right now filling the black
hole in the public finances of course we
already got some people think that black
hole could be about 62 billion pounds so
the higher that is the closer you're
getting towards filling the black hole
with spending carts with getting tax
Rises and here's what the government did
Jeremy Hunt did on Monday so 32 billion
pounds worth of measures which brings in
uh extra money for the government gets
them towards that black hole but a big
decision now looming are you going to
raise benefits and earnings in line with
inflation that's really high or earnings
a bit less high with benefits if you
just raise them in line with earnings
then you save about five billion pounds
you can see that's getting higher we're
getting closer to filling that black
hole same thing with pensions if you get
rid of the triple lock raise them in
line with earnings then you save six
billion pounds and look the Gap is only
about 18 billion pounds once you've
adjusted for rounding but of course Liz
trust has said no they're going to keep
the triple lock and as a result of that
we get rid of this bar here and the Gap
goes to 25 billion pounds all of which
will make Jeremy Hunt's job a little bit
harder when it comes to that medium-term
fiscal plan